make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so I want to try something
different
in this video right I'm kind of getting
a little bored of making videos about
stories all the time so I want to try
something different and what I want to
do is I want to find an answer to two
questions in the most unbiased way that
we can
the first question does the Joker
deserve to be executed for his crimes
and the second question if he does is it
legal to do it so let's create a
situation here right let's kind of
follow in the form and function of the
Joker's history and let's say that the
Joker had committed some crime right he
committed some act and by virtue of his
direct action he took the life of
somebody else right like put a gun to
somebody's head and now they're gone
right and so as a result of that the
city of Gotham is like okay we're gonna
put this guy on trial right no Batman
has been doing this guy in Arkham Asylum
he always escapes Arkham Asylum we've
had enough of it we're gonna put this
guy on trial and then we're gonna go
from there
and so when that happens the trial
basically goes in this fashion the
prosecution is of course presenting a
case whereby the Joker is guilty for all
of his actions our president presenting
evidence for this particular crime and
so on and so forth and the defense is
trying to demonstrate the Joker's not
guilty of his crime and in an effort to
demonstrate a lack of guilt the defense
goes for the insanity plea
and so the Joker is not guilty by reason
of mental defect now the question is how
do they present this case okay so when
it comes to the insanity defense in in
the legal system this actually kind of
goes back at least in terms of the first
real huge popular case goes back to 1843
in Britain and the reason why that
matters is because the United States
legal system is largely based on English
common law right and it made sense
because the early United States settlers
were basically separatists from Britain
who defected over here once the United
States release in its earlier days as
the colonies began to form some manner
of a government in and of itself they
basically went with what they knew and
what they knew was English common law
and so in taking English common law and
adapting it to the United States a lot
of the legal precedents and a lot of
laws that have better established here
are based on English laws now as time
has progressed we've created our own
legal system of sorts it has rules that
are different from what England has but
the foundation for the most part remains
the same and so in 1843 there was the
creation of something called the
McNaughton laws I think was either in
that in-laws or McNaughton laws I'm not
sure exactly how you pronounce his name
but this came out of a case where a guy
named Daniel
and had killed a man by the name of
Edward Drummond now Edward Drummond was
not the target of Daniel McNabb it was
actually the British prime minister
named Robert Peel but Daniel McNaughton
had committed this act believing that
Drummond was Robert Peel because he had
believed he was being persecuted by the
British prime minister and the British
government the result of this is that
when the whole case went to trial
Daniel magnet and basically said I was
driven to my actions because I felt like
I was being persecuted which ultimately
led to this revelation the Daniel
magnetons cognitive understanding of the
world around him which is to say how the
world actually exists versus how Daniel
believes the world exists were not in
line that he saw the world one way when
the world was actually another that he
was not actually being persecuted and so
what this did is it allowed for a
finding of not guilty by reason of
mental defect and Daniel spent the rest
of his days in a mental asylum now this
had a huge backlash at the time and the
reason why was because it was viewed by
Queen Victoria as well as other members
of the really the British government
itself as well as the the British
monarchy that the laws or the rules laid
down that established whether or not a
person could be found found insane were
two of lacs and so in response to this
the McNaughton laws were created to
focus on cognitive reasoning to focus on
answering the question there's a person
truly understand what's going on in a
world around them and to this day the
mcnaught laws are still used right
they're still used for the most part in
a lot of different ways and they've been
expanded on this would have changed as
time has gone on but the overall G s is
that it focused on the creation of a
standard for the jury as well as
establishing two main components the
first is that when the defense comes
along and says the Joker's not guilty by
reason of insanity the jury has to
assume the Joker's sane and so what the
defense has to do is prove two things or
at least one of two things the first is
that the defense has to prove that the
Joker didn't know what he was doing at
the time that he did it but he didn't
know that he was killing a person the
second is that the defense would have to
establish that at the time the Joker
committed the act the joker didn't know
that what he was doing was wrong if
these two components are satisfied then
the Joker is deemed to be not guilty by
reason of insanity now in addition to
the minute and laws there have also been
a series of other legal doctrines that
have been introduced over the years for
example you have what's called the
irresistible impulse test and where the
Minette laws focuses on your ability to
understand the world around you the
irresistible impulse test focuses on the
notion
of whether or not your will is your own
which is to say it was outside of your
own reasonable control you may not have
wanted to but ultimately you felt like
you had to in 1972 there was the
introduction of what's called the model
Penal Code and this was introduced by
the American Law Institute which is
really like a panel of of legal experts
that basically established kind of a new
rule for insanity and offer the idea
that a person that does not possess
quote unquote substantial capacity
either to appreciate the criminality of
his conduct or to conform his conduct to
the requirements of the law could be
found not guilty by reason of mental
insanity and in 1984 and what are the
more recent rulings there was the
comprehensive Crime Control Act which
basically kind of brought back or or saw
us return to the notion of understanding
the difference between right and wrong
based on existing societal laws and so
if you committed that act and didn't
understand that killing a person was
wrong well then you could be found not
guilty by reason of mental defect and so
with all that out of the way there's a
couple questions that we need to ask
about this you know what this this mock
trial that we're doing more or less and
this question of whether or not the
Joker is truly insane and whether or not
he should be executed and whether or not
it's legal right so the first question
we have to ask here is how does the
Joker see the world which is to say does
he see the world the way it truly is or
does he see the world the way he
believes it is and the reality is that
the Joker sees the world the way he
believes it is he made a conscious
choice this goes back to the story of
The Killing Joke the most consistently
reviewed or consistently perceived
origin of the Joker and in that story it
just focuses along this idea that all
that ever takes is one bad day and where
would be easy to look at that and say
the Joker went insane in reality he
didn't there's this really good
monologue he does where he's talking
about the notion of like walking down
memory lane and experiencing these bad
things in our past or reminding
ourselves of these bad things that we've
dealt with and where he's talking about
these memories he asks can we live
without them memories are what our
reason is based upon if we cannot face
them we deny reason itself although why
not we are contractually tied down to
rationality there is no sanity clause so
when you find yourself locked and
through an unpleasant train of thought
heading for the places in your past
where the screaming is unbearable
remember there's always madness madness
is the emergency exit the the Joker in
that moment at the invent were really in
the end of his origin when he first
became the Joker chose that but he gave
in to his darker side he gave in to the
part of himself that just
to hell with it all I'm just gonna go do
whatever it is that I want to do I don't
care about the rules of society or
anything along those lines making that
rational choice and putting himself on
that path really I think demonstrates
the fact that the Joker is not truly
insane the next question here is does
the Joker know what he's doing when he
commits these crimes and the answer to
that question is yes during the story of
Batman death of the family by Scott
Snyder there's a point where the Joker
confronts Batman just before he reveals
to Bruce and he knows his identity as
well as the identities of all the other
members of the bat family and what he
does here is he references the role of
the Jester and he says the jesters job
is to entertain but he often has another
job to a deeper job and that's to
deliver bad news to the King the worst
news of the kingdom the fleet has holes
the army turned pacifist the children's
hands have rotted off and they can't
caught four fairies anymore and that's
all I've ever tried to do for you bring
you the worst news of your own heart so
you might survive it laugh at it even
and become strong now what this shows is
that the Joker understands what it is
that he's doing not only that the
motivation of the Joker is predicated on
making Batman better and so all he does
do some pretty heinous things it's not
arbitrary it doesn't seem to have any
real lack of rhyme or reason to it it's
done to fulfill a particular purpose
however this is both expanded on and
complicated by two other factors the
next factor really comes from Batman
legends of the Dark Knight when the
Joker is essentially mortally wounded
and then subjected to the Lazarus pits
and under normal circumstances
individuals who are resurrected to the
Lazarus pits experience momentary
insanity The Joker however reverts to a
more lucid and sane state and then
demonstrates an understanding that his
actions are wrong and so what this means
is that the Joker seems to have some
sort of insane element to him however
when you go back to the events of scott
Snyder's death of the family when Batman
or when Bruce Wayne approaches Joker at
the end of the story and confronts Joker
with the knowledge that jover seems to
know the identity of Bruce as well as
the rest of the bat family the Joker
doesn't care the only real thing the
Joker cares about is continuing the game
between himself and Batman but the next
question to ask here is does the Joker
know that what he's doing is wrong and a
build on that does the
Curnow the difference between right and
wrong and again the answer here is yes
referencing the story yet again of Scott
Snyder's death of the family there's a
point whereby the Joker is talking to
Harvey Dent and what he says is you know
it's all true all it took was a little
acid to the face and everything you
stood for got thrown out the window and
it turns out you were just waiting for
the chance to pretend to be one of the
gangsters you used to lock away and heck
in this city that brand of justice is
perfect the kind of justice that's
meaningless where one side of the coin
is just as good as the other where
there's no difference between right and
wrong and so what this means as the
Joker understands the difference between
right and wrong
if the Joker didn't understand right and
wrong if he didn't grasp these two
concepts they would be lost on him
they'd be totally irrelevant to him a
really good example of this is in the
movie sphere when Samuel Jackson's
character is talking about an organism
that couldn't be killed and what he says
is that a creature that couldn't be
killed wouldn't think that killing was
right or wrong it would have no concept
of it and with the Joker it would be the
same way if the idea of good and evil
were lost on the Joker then he wouldn't
really consider himself doing anything
good or evil and wouldn't understand the
concepts instead as far as the Joker is
concerned he would just be committing a
series of acts that's no different than
breathing or picking up a pencil or pin
or something of that sort but the fact
that the Joker can look at Harvey Dent
and make a case for a type of
lawlessness where right and wrong don't
exist means the Joker understands the
concepts of right and wrong which means
that he understands that what he's doing
is either right or wrong and by virtue
of the fact that Joker understands the
notion of justice means the Joker
understands what justice stands for ergo
the Joker understands what he's doing is
wrong and so the final question to ask
here as to whether or not the Joker can
be determined to be insane is the
question is the Joker in control of his
own actions physically yes he is
mentally no he's not the reality here is
that while the Joker did choose to let
in the madness of his own life at the
end of The Killing Joke and surrender to
his darker side as time has passed this
darker element has really become more of
a compulsion than anything else the need
for Batman to be the antithesis to
himself is an absolute aspect of his
character and this is laid out perfectly
in Batman issue number 49 by Tom King in
a conversation with Catwoman as to why
it is that she can't marry
Swayne The Joker says we all loved him
we wanted him to love us that's
everything
but he never loved us he always loved
you all I'd have to do is kill everyone
Harvey Edward Oswald on and on me but
not you it'd be so easy and he'd be so
happy but Selina don't you understand
that's why I'm here now with you if I
did that if you did this wedding if he
found some joy he lose the frown and the
costume and the big black bat he can't
be happy and also be Batman
I need him to stand between me and
everything you don't understand no one
understands I can kill everything and I
need him to stop me
this statement combined with that man
death of the family both at the point
where the Joker reveals that everything
he does is for the purpose of making
Batman stronger as well as Bruce Wayne
coming to the realization that yes the
Joker knows his identity but doesn't
care and the Joker only cares about the
cat-and-mouse game between the two of
them illustrates the fact that yes Joker
forms his own schemes
yes Joker engages in his own plans but
at the end of the day the mind of Joker
in terms of how he views the world and
all those things is basically secondary
to the compulsion that the Joker has to
constantly engage in an act whereby
Batman will ultimately track him down
it's a compulsive action it's a
compulsive behavior and is something the
Joker simply cannot control and so given
what we've laid out here by virtue of
the Joker's own admission the Joker does
understand what he's doing when he's
committing these crimes The Joker does
understand the difference between right
and wrong and the Joker does understand
that what he's doing is wrong despite
the fact that this is a compulsion and
so what this means is the Joker does not
appear to be insane because only one out
of these four particular principles has
been found as being satisfied by virtue
of what the definition of insanity calls
for when it comes to a trial however if
we go with the universally accepted
standard that the Joker is actually
insane then the question becomes should
the Joker be executed anyway and is it
legal to do it in order to answer this
we have to ask the question is there any
possibility that the Joker can be
rehabilitated or in some way his mental
illness can be corrected to allow him to
become a productive member of society
and the answer to that question is
and this comes from a couple different
sources the first source is pretty much
everything we've laid out so far
especially when it comes to the
irresistible impulse this idea that he
has to have this game between himself
and Batman this combined with the
various schemes that he's committed over
the years and his willful disregard for
human life shows that the only
overriding factor that Joker has is that
this game continued on this is
compounded by Batman cacophony issues
one through three when the Joker says
that he won't stop killing until Batman
himself is dead and so what this means
is that so long as Batman is alive the
Joker won't stop he'll keep going and
going and going he'll escape Arkham
Asylum the way that he always does none
of the mental health institutions will
be able to hold him he'll always find a
way to get back to engaging into his
schemes and he'll always be captured and
this cycle will continue and so to
answer the question should the Joker be
executed the answer is yes because the
Joker represents a clear and present
danger to the mortal lives of the
citizens of Gotham and will kill as many
of them as he needs to in order to
ensure the game between himself and
Batman continues on the problem with
this is it it's not legal for that to
happen
this was established in 1986 and a
Supreme Court case Ford versus
Wainwright where by a guy named Alvin
Bernard Ford was convicted of murder in
1974 and sentenced to death in the state
of Florida
however Ford's mental health had
diminished to the point that by the time
his execution was supposed to have
happened he had exhibited signs of
paranoid schizophrenia and under the
Eighth Amendment the Supreme Court ruled
that executing somebody who is mentally
ill amounted to cruel and unusual
punishment and so the result was that if
a person's mental competency for
execution or trial was in question that
they would in turn be given a trial to
establish their mental competency and if
they were deemed to be mentally ill
execution would no longer be allowed and
so that gives us the answer to the
question should the Joker be executed
yes because it's what's best for Gotham
City can he legally be executed no not
according to the Supreme Court of the
United States of America without being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end this was fun I enjoyed this I
know you guys think that in the comments
section it will deal with something else
do it like a different character or
something along those lines and I will
catch you all later
whose we've got some new patrons in our
top tiers over on patreon.com slash
comments explain I want to give a shout
out to Jason see Austin s Austin H
Phillip and Austin B as well as Steven Z
Eagle F Joey M and Jeff are as well as
Genesis 916 as always we just usually
keep the last name to it initial it
helps you guys to maintain your
anonymity some of you guys are expressed
concerned about having like your first
and last name thrown out there for the
world to see I do not blame you for you
guys who have joined up as part of our
patreon tiers that are eligible for Rob
Court honor guard rings those whose
rings have been sent out you should
already have them if you're a new person
who just joined up and you've been part
of this to here for a month your ring
will be mailed out to you so I want to
say thank you guys for being patrons
[Music]